[Music]
hi oh wow
alright yeah so hi hi everyone here
[Music]
since this is jazz college I'm guessing
that most of you are JavaScript
developers people are talking about how
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the web is it's just amazing one more
reason you should stick to JavaScript
it's it's just a really really cool stop
talking about this so this is a rock and
it rocks pretty hard
in the way that rocks so I'd like to
read your column nobody sits like this
rock you rock rock
throughout just sits and is you show us
how to just sit here and that's what we
need
[Music]
this is too abstract I can't use this
how do I make it make more sense it
doesn't make sense you see it doesn't
make sense
how do I make it make more sense brains
brains I deleted it and brain brains
obviously it does melt your brain spring
rains in the open brain brain brain
brain and I really do this in the old
days can we do stuff
[Music]
it would just jump beauties around time
of application
[Music]
during the runtime of application
[Music]
try to make a dial-up connection
[Music]
you
[Applause]